[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMIT GANDHI: Hi, my
name is Amit Gandhi.
And I'm a graduate
researcher at MIT.
Welcome to the
series on exploring
fairness and machine learning
for international development.
In this module, we
will have an example
of how an organization would
go about implementing machine
learning and what some of
the ethical challenges that
may arise are.
This module primarily
focuses on decisions
that are made at the
organizational level.
But it is important for both
organizational decision makers
and machine learning
implementers
to consider these interactions.
In this case study,
we will be taking
the role of a chief technology
officer of a social enterprise
to provide solar lighting
products in East Africa.
The mission of the company is
to provide affordable lighting
solutions to people
living in poverty.
And the company started
off by providing
high-quality, inexpensive
solar light, so a replacement
for kerosene lanterns.
Over time, the company has
grown and increased its product
offering to include large solar
home systems and along the way
has implemented pay-as-you-go
models so that households can
afford to purchase
these larger systems.
The way pay-as-you-go models
work are that you provide
the solar lighting
infrastructure as a loaned
asset to individuals.
And they pay you back over time
through mobile money payments,
until the full value of
the asset is recovered.
The company has been meticulous
about keeping records
from transactions
from their user base.
And as a result, you have access
to both demographic information
and payment history for
all of your clients.
The information you
have from your users
includes age, gender,
occupation, location,
and household income.
As you look at expanding
the social impact
of your enterprise, you
realize that this data
can be analyzed to
determine a creditworthiness
metric for your customers.
Additionally, you could
provide this information
to banks or microfinance
institutions
so that they can give
loans to your client base.
Machine learning
is a powerful tool
that you can use to implement
this credit scoring metric.
However, you do not have
data scientists or machine
learning experts
within your team that
can implement this solution.
You also do not know
how accurate or powerful
an algorithm you
developed could be.
So you do not want to spend
the resources to build
a full team [INAUDIBLE]
on a small pilot with some
of your users in Uganda.
As a resourceful company
with engineering staff,
you could either have
some of your engineers
implement a machine
learning solution
using off-the-shelf products or
work with a third party company
to implement the solution
for credit scoring.
Let's pause this case
study for a second
and examine the pros and
cons of the decisions that
need to be made.
It is important to
consider perspectives
from both the machine
learning implementer as well
as the organizations to
understand the thoughts
and complexities that go
into developing a solution.
Doing it in-house without
a trained data scientist
will likely involve
implementation of a black box
solution.
While someone with no
background in machine learning
could get a solution up
and running fairly quickly,
there are several nuances in the
design that may get overlooked.
Allowing a third
party consultant
to implement your solution would
solve many of these issues,
though you may lack both
in-house capabilities
to understand how your
model is being implemented
and maintain it moving forward.
Let's assume that one way or
another, the credit scoring
algorithm gets built.
Without paying attention
to fairness in this setup,
several issues may arise.
First, you may find that as you
analyze your historical data,
that certain groups of
people have different default
rates than others.
For example, women may have a
lower default rate than men.
And you may decide that
as an organization,
you want to be fair and
gender blind in your loan
determination.
The slide shows an example of
what different loan rates look
like for what men and women.
To implement fairness,
a naive implementer
may first try to use fairness
through unawareness, which
means that you simply
hide gender information
while building your models.
Depending on correlations
within your data
and how relevant gender
is to default rates,
your models could
still predict gender
and use that in the model.
Second, since your data shows
a difference in default rates,
you have to actively decide
how to correct for that.
In the case of loans,
different approaches
to implement fairness may have
a trade-off with the accuracy
of your algorithms.
Third, the type of algorithm
the implementer uses
could have trade-offs as well.
Some algorithms may be faster
at the cost of accuracy.
Others may be more accurate
at the cost of explainability
or understandability.
I won't go more in-depth
on these topics,
because we will discuss
them more in future modules.
However, I do want to highlight
a couple of important concepts.
First, implementing a
machine learning algorithm
is not an objective process.
In your implementation, you
are both designing a technology
and making decisions,
both of which
introduce your biases
into the system.
To think that outcomes from
a computer are objective
is just a fantasy.
Second, open
communication between you
and the implementer on your
values as an organization.
And decisions that they
are making are critical.
Third, you need a way to audit
your data and your algorithms
if you want to
have a fair system.
Let's move on, assuming you were
able to work with a consultant
to build a satisfactory
solution to your algorithm.
And you're able to demonstrate
significant success
with your pilot
in western Uganda.
You now want to scale your
model to other parts of Uganda
and East Africa.
At this point, it is
important to pay attention
to the representativeness
of your data.
Are there large differences
between the types of users
you have in western
Uganda and eastern Uganda?
How about the users in
Uganda and Tanzania?
You need to make sure that you
are collecting representatives'
data as you scale
your solution, which
involves significant
testing and auditing.
Additionally, you
want to make sure
that changes within
your population
do not suddenly
affect your results.
For example, if a kerosene tax
were imposed by the government,
would your model no
longer be accurate?
How could you build in support
within your organization
to make sure you can
react to changes?
Thank you for taking the
time to take this course.
We hope that you'll
continue to watch the rest
of the modules in the series.
[MUSIC PLAYING]